man with power or be neither policy no
principle no one is different no one is
not wrong if Superman were here what
would you want to say to him but my
family too had dreams to look him in his
eye and ask him how he decides which
lives count and which ones do not
there's a new kind of mean in him he is
angry and he's hunting
I didn't kill those men if that's what
they think this is what makes you such a
good reporter stuff like this still
shocks I'm older now than my father ever
was this may be the only thing I do
matters so fools the house of way
God is all-powerful he cannot be
ultimate in the rose on the I sets if
you force it to and I like that words
don't stop you know what stops him fist
whatever of God
that dream is all some people have to
all that gives them hope you know god is
good as
man made a world where standing together
is impossible
we have to
you
hey youtubers is charlie so we finally
got to see Jenna Malone who's playing
Barbara Gordon so this is going to be a
breakdown of the Ultimate Edition
trailer this is for the blu-ray they're
releasing all told it's about an extra
half hour of footage bringing the total
running time of the movie closer to
three hours so what it does is it just
adds a bunch of extra characters a bunch
of contextual scenes and just balances
the tone of the film a little bit better
but I still think of it as more of a
Batman film with Superman and Wonder
Woman in it just totally Batman
dominates the film which makes me
excited for the Batman solo film but
Justice League is gonna feel very
different like they've definitely made
some adjustments behind the scenes
here's the new stuff that they add it
back in so a whole bunch more of the
Superman scenes that are early in the
film with him at Lois's apartment more
Clark Kent reporter scenes like him
talking to this person here learning
about more things that the Batman has
been doing recently that frame his
opinion of him the idea they're trying
to get across in the film as the Batman
is definitely crossing the line
especially compared to other versions of
the Batman you've seen before on screen
he kills people so Clark is just
learning about that to say okay this is
bad I have to stop this there's more
visual effects sequences of him doing
cool Superman things especially the
desert scene there is an idea of a very
fun Superman in this movie but a lot of
those scenes got left on the cutting
room floor so he does have fun he has
jokes it's just that the theatrical cut
with all this stuff left out just rushed
into that conflict so things get taken
to crazytown way faster than they
normally would in a Superman film
usually superman starts out at like this
really average baseline so he's joking
around just being a normal person then
there's a few more places for the
character to go when things get crazy
you know you're in deep [ __ ] when
Superman gets serious but he's not able
to make a joke about something or give
you hope in any given moment you know
you're in big trouble so that's a lot of
what DC is doing in the comic books
right now with rebored just reminding
you that these are all very hopeful
characters even Batman rebirth is a vast
departure from say like the Frank Miller
version of Batman which allowed to the
film takes inspiration from it reads
more like a frank miller story than it
does like a traditional DC story but
just like the new Superman scenes
provide more context for the character
you learn a little bit more about his
viewpoint where he's coming from and why
he makes certain decisions the same
thing is true of all the new Batman
scenes we get to see
Malone Barbara Gordon who although she's
a Batman character provides some point
of crossover because she interacts with
Lois Lane but if you remember that scene
in Captain America Civil War where Tony
Stark is confronted by alfre woodard
scare achter who said my son died
because of the things you did while
calling yourself a hero he was your
collateral damage this is scene like
that just adding some more context for
Superman seeing the collateral damage
that he's causing so the extra scenes
don't change the story a whole lot it
just adds more context because Lex
Luthor for instance we have that scene
with him commuting with the Kryptonian
ship where he learns about mother boxes
in this greater threat that's coming to
Earth he's basically talking about the
new gods and dark side so it informs Lex
Luthor's position a little bit better
the other reason they cut a bunch of
cool stuff at a Batman V Superman was to
get that pg-13 rating because i think it
was closer to an R in terms of violence
just a level of violence in it so
everybody be sure to check it out and
let me know what you think like what do
you think about the idea of an r-rated
Batman movie that actually pretty crazy
but I don't think they would ever do it
pretty much all the other Studios making
comic book films after Deadpool blew up
said that you know we're not really
changing our plans in terms of movie
ratings I think Suicide Squad probably
the closest they get to something like
that but let me know in the comments if
they ever did an r-rated DC movie which
character would you want them to do for
it like maybe a Lobo they're talking
about doing a Lobo film that might be
fun as an r-rated film just because that
character is so crazy I don't know if
making a gotham city sirens movie like
the harley quinn spin-off movie that
they're talking about I don't know that
making that are rated would make that
better but let me know which DC movie
you would want to see are rated in the
lighter corner of the DC Universe of
Stephen Amell is Casey Jones and Ninja
Turtles this weekend be sure to go see
it eat pizza in the theater I'll be
seeing it tonight i'll post my
non-spoiler review tomorrow it is going
to be a fun trip back to my childhood
most of my time in the fandom was spent
with the original animated series in the
original movies but I am really excited
and I'm really happy for Stephen Amell
that his film career starting to take
off I think it's going to be a lot of
fun so be sure to subscribe to get that
video i'll be posting some guardians of
the galaxy later tonight they just been
talking about the guardians of the
galaxy to film so a lot of comic book
stuff dropping this week why you guys
wait for my next video to post you can
click here to learn all about marvel's
new civil war event
just crazy WTF just happened so I did a
big video for it and you can click here
to learn all about the flash season 3
doing flashpoint things from the comics
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight